hello and welcome to the unboxing today
I've got here what has got to be the
most highly requested exam and video
topic that I've ever had and it is to
cover the any ET exam that's the
national eligibility and entrance test
conducted in India for students who want
to go on to study medicine
it's an undergraduate exam so this would
be set by students say between 17 and 25
who want to get into a variety of
medical degrees at university and it's a
very competitive exam now in this video
I'm just going to take a little bit of a
look through this exam and see what it
entails I'm also going to do something a
little bit different today and I've made
this little report card to give you a
little bit more idea as I've got scope a
difficulty time pressure and
competitiveness of this exam living way
to try and measure some of those factors
and that's just going to be my opinion
so Who am I to be judging this exam in
the first place I guess I am no one to
be judging this exam I'm an Australian
and I've never had to sit this exam but
having said that I am someone who has
completed my own undergraduate degree I
did physics and maths and I'm someone
who has set a lot of exams of my own and
looking at other people's exams has
become a bit of an interest of mine so
I'll give you my thoughts on this and
you can see what you think this is the
2019 version of the exam so it's fresh
off the press and I think people have
just sat this recently let's just jump
into it so this is the exam and let's
have a look at the front page first the
test is three hours long and has a
hundred and eighty questions each
question carries four marks of each
correct response you get the four marks
but for each incorrect response you will
lose one mark so that's a bit of a yikes
already some pretty standard stuff here
and there note that people aren't
allowed to use a calculator so that
makes all those calculations especially
for the physics section
all that bad harder we can turn over and
look at the first page and this is
starting off straightaway with the
biology section or to be more correct
it's the botany and zoology section
these biology questions take up the
first 90 questions which is in a higher
half of the exam so it makes sense that
an exam for people that want to go into
medicine is extremely heavy in the
biology questions that does make some
sense but then after question 90 we go
on and we're now on the physics section
so there are 45 physics questions and
then after that there are 45 chemistry
questions so it does cover physics
chemistry and biology there is no math
section and definitely a big waiting to
those biology questions after the front
just for a bit of a taste we can take a
read of this very first bio question
here it says from evolutionary point of
view retention of the female gametophyte
with developing young embryo on the
parent sporophyte for some time is first
observed in which of these four answers
now to be honest this question is one I
would do terribly on there are several
words here that I don't know the
definition of I did bio at high school
it was a few years ago now but I did do
well in it and I do have quite a good
memory of what we did but it looks like
this is probably more in depth and I
covered in my school bio class we go on
from there to cover things like
reproduction DNA things about global
warming it seems hominids so you know a
bit of evolution in here and it looks
like yeah a lot of stuff covering
diversity of life as well as structure
and function of biological systems we've
got human biology mixed in with plant
biology and it's really broad I am kind
of surprised at the way that different
biological phew
kind of all mixed and together like
there seems to be no very clear
separation of topics
there's even I guess a bit of
environmental biology with a question
here that jumps out to my eye about
which of the following methods is the
most suitable for the disposal of
nuclear waste and the answer of shooting
the waste into space amuses me but I
think the correct answer is actually
number two burying the waste within
rocks deep below the earth's surface and
as we go on through the sections yeah we
can see that a lot of these questions
would take you having done a lot of
reading and a lot of memorization of
biological ideas beforehand because it
would be possible to answer some of
these questions you know in that very
short period of time that you have to
answer each one if it's already at the
top of your heads things like knowing
already which purines are found in the a
and RNA or how the drug heroin is
synthesized it's a bit of another
strange wonder maybe yeah so definitely
a lot of questions here and you'd have
to be going into this exam with your
mind almost exploding full of all these
things that you don't want to forget
because there could just be a question
on them so let's go on to the physics
section which is just starting here now
we've got all your usual suspects again
we've got simple harmonic motion
we've got kinematics we've got lenses
we've got some radiation
we've got circuits and electronics and
we've got things like you know the
collision of particles things to do with
the conservation of momentum more here
including dimensional analysis
thermodynamics and again all the
questions are sort of mixed into each
other they're not like separated out
into sections or anything I think some
of these circuit questions are actually
pretty cool
this is stuff that I didn't really study
until I was already in an electronics
course
part of my physics degree so I kind of
wish I had exposure to this earlier on
now you probably don't appreciate the
questions when you're actually studying
for this exam and all physics and
chemistry and by Oprah bit of a
nightmare because you're having to learn
it in a way that you're being tested and
maybe you don't have time to even
appreciate these ideas because you're
just having to cram so many of them and
learn so many of them for such an
intense exam which covers so much
because physics is my area I'll solve
one of the physics problems as a way to
give you some idea of maybe how involved
each question is maybe how much working
you could expect to see for each one of
these now I'm going to pick this
question here number 132 a solid
cylinder of mass 2 kilograms and radius
4 centimeters is rotating about its axis
at the rate of 3 rpm so I'll draw a
little cylinder here and it's rotating
about its axis there now what do we know
we know what it is rotating at and we
know that we're slowing it down to a
stop so we know that our final Omega at
angular velocity is going to be equal to
zero and our initial Omega is going to
be equal to three rpm now that's
revolutions per minute so to convert
that into radians per second we would go
3 times 2 pi over 60 that would be 6 PI
over 60 which we could cancel 2 PI over
10 rads per second now in the question
we're being asked about the torque
required to bring it to a stop so
hopefully something that we've
remembered going into this exam is a way
to find talk and that is in rotational
mechanics the I so the moment of inertia
times the angular acceleration
now if you've also memorized so yeah
it's a lot to cram into your mind but if
you've also memorized the moment of
inertia for a cylinder rotating like
this you would know that it is M R
squared over two I guess that kind of is
fair enough to know if you're studying
physics because you do a lot of moment
of inertia questions with different
shapes but still you you wouldn't want
to be doubting yourself on whether
you've got that one correct about any
way i times the acceleration now we have
the mass in the radius so all we need
now is this angular acceleration or in
this case it would be decelerating to
zero now what we need to know to be able
to get that is a kinematic equation for
rotational motion now the one that
particular we're going to need to use is
that the final angular velocity squared
is equal to the initial squared plus 2
alpha times theta so that's the you know
basically the distance or the angular
distance you've moved through the
angular acceleration so if you're not
already doing a lot of rotational
mechanics problems you be like where on
earth did this come from but if you're
familiar with kinematics at all this is
sort of an analogue to one of the linear
kinematic equations and again I feel
like it's something you need to memorize
for the sake of this exam which you know
it would be easier if they had a formula
sheet or something like that but of
course this is a pretty difficult exam
so let's see if we can plug things in
here and so for our cell eration
that should be the initial zero is pi
[Music]
we've got theta being 2 pi times 2 pi
because it was 2 pi revolutions but each
revolution itself was 2 pi we can solve
this and I'll just write it up here by
taking that over there and dividing by
these numbers you would end up with
and then plugging that into here with
two kgs and four centimeters squared
you'd end up with your talk being equal
to two times ten to the minus six Newton
and that corresponds to this answer to
here so that was a little involved and
it wasn't trivial by any means although
you did have to kind of come in with
these memorized formulas which make it
so much easier for you the very act of
knowing what to actually do and what
process to take can trip you up and
there are plenty of points even like
this finding the theta here which you
might get a little bit confused because
they using two pi revolutions can be a
little bit of a tricky thing to say and
then to realize it's two pi squared now
having worked through a little bit of a
problem I will say that these physics
problems don't seem as involved as the j
ee advanced physics questions i would
say that maybe make sense as well I
think the j ee advanced questions which
i have looked a little bit at in videos
before and together the plenty of hate
and comments about it would make sense
that those problems are more involved
and have more calculations I think
because for that exam you're wanting to
go on to be an engineer rather than
going into medicine where maybe the ayah
was more of the focus but you know that
that's still probably quite involved in
I think that's a roundabout
right for the amount of working some of
these physics questions would take you
so let's move on now that's the end of
our physics questions and we actually
started on to our chemistry ones down
here 136 or so start of our chemistry
and from here on out it's all chemistry
so yeah you can see we've got some like
organic chemistry we've got things about
bonding or
the tools ions I guess obviously you're
going to have to be pretty familiar with
the periodic table at this point you
asked about the elements here you're
asked about solutions and you even have
to do you know a little bit of
calculations and some of these questions
were asked about amino acids the
hydrogen atom and transitions we're
asked about thermal stability organic
chemistry again definitely a pretty
broad range of chemistry topics and that
is our last page from there so let's
have a think about this exam and and
what we just saw so I've got my little
report card here now I'm going to put a
meet and it has our name the scope of
the subjects mentioned is pretty high
like within biology within physics and
chemistry you cover basically you know
the scope of those subjects this exam
doesn't have any questions or sections
focusing on math in particular like
exams like the je e do so I'll take math
out of the scope but having said that I
will give this scope an a because it
does you know within those subjects
basically everything seems like it's
fair game there now in terms of the
difficulty yes there's a difficult exam
obviously to learn so much content and
the level at which you need to know is
not trivial like we worked through that
physics problem and it was a few steps
like I said I wouldn't say the
difficulty of those physics questions is
as high as the je e but still definitely
you know you need to know your physics
to get by so I'll give that an A as well
now the next two categories are where I
really think this any ETA exam becomes
very challenging so in terms of time
pressure like I mentioned there are a
hundred and eighty questions and a
hundred and eighty minutes to do all of
them but that's not even taking into
account that you'll need
to save time maybe even 10 to 15 minutes
of your exam to fill in the little
bubbles on your multiple choice answer
sheet because yeah like it's multiple
choice you need to record your answers
as you go along and then make sure
you've colored them in correctly so
that's actually going to take away from
the total amount of time you have and
I'd say it's maybe fair to say you've
actually only got about 45 seconds maybe
50 seconds for each question by the time
all that's done and that actually is
kind of crazy like even me working out
that Philips problem before it took me
more than that just to write it down and
I already felt like I knew what I was
doing it doesn't really leave you any
time to be sitting around wondering what
to do and what the correct approaches I
guess that's where a lot of memorization
can really help you I feel especially
for maybe that biology section I do in
general think that biology sections
where you can kind of memorize the
answers to things you can move through
them faster than say a math or a physics
section where you actually do have to
make calculations for the most part for
most of the questions so the time
pressure for this insane amount of
questions in this amount of time I'm
going to give it an A+ and then lastly
is a really big component of the exam
which you can't really capture just from
looking at the paper like I do and like
the previous videos I've made about
exams especially Indian exams you know
it's really hard to capture how
competitive they really are and in the
end it doesn't really matter how many
problems in here you find easy and that
you can do because what really matters
is how many questions everyone else
sitting this exam could do because what
matters is your final ranking amongst
all your peers so in this case the
inherent difficulty of the exam really
depends on how others find it as well
you can think you did really well but if
everyone feels that way
you might come out with kind of a poor
ranking I have also heard that because
students in India really do study
intensely for this exam and try their
hardest
maybe they tend to score quite well
which means that even getting one
question wrong and messing up in one
spot where you shouldn't have can
actually bring down your ranking quite
considerably from the numbers I've seen
it appears that over a million students
would sit this exam and prepare to sit
this exam but there only seems to be
about sixty thousand seats for people to
get in so for that reason I think this
exam is insanely competitive and that
really brings up its difficulty rating
so I'm going to give it competitiveness
a + + + now thank you to everyone who
has in the past left me a comment or a
message suggesting that I cover this
exam I hope I did it justice for you and
that you found my opinion slightly
interesting or is slightly valuable my
best wishes to people who are preparing
for this or other exams I know it's
always exam season somewhere across the
world try to stay happy and positive
throughout your studies and I hope you
get to the other side of it thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]